Speaker 1: Well, yesterday was an historic
day.
There was last minute testimony scheduled
in the January six committee from a former
aide to Trump chief of staff Mark Meadows.
Her name is Cassidy Hutchinson.
This was scheduled relatively last minute.
It was expected to be explosive.
And it was in fact, it was so potentially
explosive that I even canceled yesterday's
bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: And if I cancel that, you know,
something's big is going on.
And indeed it was.
Yesterday we received testimony from Cassidy
Hutchinson, former aide to former Trump chief
of staff Mark Meadows, that Donald Trump knew
there were people at his January six rally
with guns and he wanted the metal detectors
turned off so more people could get in saying
they don't want to hurt me.
Trump was so determined to go to the Capitol
with the rioters that he allegedly assaulted
a Secret Service officer and attempted to
commandeer his vehicle.
He also threw his lunch at the wall, leaving
a ketchup stain dribbling down the walls of
the White House and so many other claims.
Let's get right into it like nothing we've
ever heard before.
Speaker 3: The impression from Mr. Meadows
that the off the record movement to the Capitol
was so possible and likely to happen that
that body had more information.
So once the president had gotten into the
vehicle with body, he thought that they were
going up to the Capitol.
And when Bobby had related to him, we're not
we don't have the assets to do it.
It's not secure.
We're going back to the West Wing.
The president had very strong, very angry
response to that.
Tony described him as being irate.
The president said something to the effect
of, I'm the acting president.
Take me up to the Capitol now.
To which Bobby responded, Sir, we have to
go back to the West Wing, sir.
The president reached out towards the front
of the vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
while.
Mr. Engels grabbed his arm, said, Sir, you
need to take your hand off the steering wheel.
We're going back to the West Wing.
We're not going to the capital.
Mr. Trump then used his free hand to lunge
towards Bobby Engle.
And when Mr. Renato had recounted the stories,
we had motioned towards his clavicles.
While.
And was Mr. Engle in the room, as Mr. Bernardo
told you this story?
He was.
Did Mr. Engle correct or disagree with any
part of this story for Mr. Tornado?
Mr. Engle did not correct or disagree with
any part of the story.
Did Mr. Engle or Mr. Varnado ever after that
tell you that what Mr. Tornado had just said
was untrue?
Neither Mr. Rinaldo nor Mr. Engle told me
ever that it was untrue.
Speaker 1: Wow.
Wow.
Assaulting.
The allegations here are assaulting a Secret
Service agent attempting to commandeer the
vehicle.
And I guess, I mean, I don't know that Donald
Trump knows how to drive.
I'm not aware of him ever driving, but I guess
attempting to redirect the vehicle towards
where he wanted to go and a determination
to go to the Capitol.
Now, this is arguably the most sort of salacious
allegation, but the undertone of all of it
is a degree of premeditation and foreknowledge
that armed, violent people would be coming
to the Capitol on January 6th and a desire
for them to be there and a desire for them
to wreak havoc and an expectation that they
would.
No one was surprised in the Trump Circle that
this is the way it went on January 6th.
Incredible allegations.
Now, there are now reports that some of the
Secret Service officers mentioned dispute
and are willing to, well, get them under oath.
Okay.
What we have right now is Cassidy Hutchinson
under oath.
And we have Trump posting untruth, social
or truth essential and claims to reporters
that Secret Service will put him under oath.
Right now, this is what we have under oath.
Okay, second series of allegations that are
absolutely outrageous, but not particularly
shocking that Trump threw a fit so large that
he launched his food at the wall.
Of course, his lunch include catch up, unclear
whether they were dinosaur shaped chicken
nuggets or what he was eating with the ketchup.
That's not a detail we have.
But Trump losing it and leaving ketchup dripping
down the wall.
Speaker 3: The physical altercation that Ms..
Hutchinson described in the presidential vehicle
was not the first time that the president
had become very.
Speaker 1: Oh, sorry.
And that's.
So first, we're looking at we're looking at
one other clip here, but we're going to get
to the catch.
Speaker 3: Up injury about issues relating
to the election on December one, 2020.
Attorney General Barr said in an interview
that the Department of Justice had not found
evidence of widespread election fraud sufficient
to change the outcome of the election.
Ms. Hutchinson, how did the President react
to hearing that news?
Around the time that I understand the AP article
went live.
I remember hearing noise coming from down
the hallway, so I poked my head out of the
office.
I saw the valet walking towards our office.
He had said, Get the chief down to the dining
room.
The president wants him to mark one down to
the dining room.
Came back to the office a few minutes later
after Mark had returned.
I left the office and went down to the dining
room and I noticed that the door is propped
open and the valet was inside the dining room,
changing the tablecloth off of the dining
room table.
He motioned for me to come in and then pointed
towards the front of the room near the fireplace
mantel and the TV, where I first noticed there
was catch up dripping down the wall and there's
a shattered porcelain plate on the floor.
The valet had articulated that the president
was extremely angry at the attorney general's
AP interview and had thrown his lunch against
the wall.
Which was causing them to have to clean up.
So I grabbed a towel and started wiping the
catch up off of the wall to help the valet
out.
And he said something to the effect of, he's
really ticked off about this.
So I would stay clear of him for right now.
He's really, really ticked off about this
right now.
Speaker 1: Wow.
Ketchup.
Ketchup down the wall.
And apparently, Trump would regularly throw
dishes.
And that was also testified to sort.
Speaker 3: Of wiping the catch up off of the
wall to help the valet out.
And he said something to the effect of, he's
really ticked off about this.
I said I would stay clear of him for right
now.
He's really, really ticked off about this
right now.
And Miss Hutchinson, was this the only instance
that you are aware of where the president
threw dishes?
It's not.
And are there other instances in the dining
room that you recall where he expressed his
anger?
There were there were several times throughout
my tenure with the chief of staff that I was
aware of either throwing dishes or flipping
the tablecloth to let all the contents of
the table go onto the floor.
Speaker 1: And there you go, just grabbing
the tablecloth and pushing it up and knocking
everything over.
This was an unhinged man.
And most importantly, all, I mean, listen,
throwing ketchup at the wall from your attendees
that your chicken tenders that you're eating,
this is not a crime.
It does go to Trump's instability on and on
and on.
But so far, there has been no dispute whatsoever
that Donald Trump knew and wanted armed people
to be let beyond the magnetometers, metal
detectors, or with their firearms.
There is no dispute from witnesses that Donald
Trump was absolutely determined to get to
the Capitol with the mob.
And there is absolutely no dispute about all
of the claims that everybody Mark Meadows,
Trump, Pat Cipollone, you know, whoever they
all knew exactly that what happened on January
six was what was expected to happen.
No dispute there.
Now, one other thing.
There are some people making Cassidy Hutchinson
out to be some kind of hero.
Cassidy Hutchinson is not a hero.
Okay.
Cassidy Hutchinson is cooperating with an
investigation.
She if she does not cooperate.
She is not like Roger Stone or whoever.
Okay.
This is a mid-level staffer.
The legal help that could be trained upon
her if she doesn't cooperate or if she lies
under oath is extraordinary.
She was part of the MAGA crowd.
She worked for Mark Meadows and Trump.
She agreed with all of it.
She at the very end, she didn't like the way
that they were trying to steal the election.
But she is not a hero.
She's acting out of self-preservation.
She was there for a year or more.
This is the testimony that we needed 12, 14,
15, 16 months ago.
Great that she's here.
To the extent that she's telling the truth,
fantastic.
But Cassidy Hutchinson is not a hero.
She is here because she's in serious legal
jeopardy if she's not here, period.
Let's now move on to the Hang Mike Pence circumstances.
So the other big thing that came from yesterday's
testimony by a former aide to a former failed
President Trump's former chief of staff, Mark
Meadows, is that Donald Trump seemed to be
perfectly comfortable with and agreeing with
the idea of Hang Mike Pence.
Hang Mike Pence is a chant that now has notoriously
been associated with the January 6th protests.
There were right wingers chanting Hang Mike
Pence.
They built a gallows because they were mad
that Mike Pence wasn't doing what they believed
he should be doing, which is, quote, sending
the election back to the states, something
he couldn't do.
He had no power to do it.
But Trumpists believe that he did.
And they started chanting, Hang Mike Pence,
hang Mike Pence.
One of the questions that has come up is why
didn't Trump do more to ensure the safety
of Mike Pence?
Why didn't Trump do more to say, Hey, guys,
this is our great vice president?
No, no, no, no, no.
None of this hang Mike Pence stuff.
And the reason that we now know Trump didn't
do anything about it is because he agreed
with the sentiment.
Hang Mike Pence.
We now have another witness who says Trump
believed that it was reasonable to hang Mike
Pence.
Let's go to yesterday's testimony from Cassidy
Hutchinson.
Speaker 3: Wasn't until Mark hung up the phone,
handed it back to me.
I went back to my desk.
A couple minutes later, him and Pat came back,
possibly.
Eric Hershman So I am pretty sure Eric Hershman
was there.
But I'm I'm confident it was part that was
there.
I remember saying something to the effect
of, Mark, we need to do something more.
They're literally calling for the vice president
to be at home.
Right.
And Mark had responded something to the effect
of, you heard him, Pat.
He thinks Mike deserves it.
He doesn't think they're doing anything wrong.
To which Pat said something.
This is acting crazy.
We need to be doing something more.
Briefly stepped into Mark's office, and when
Mark had said something with Mark said something
to the effect of he doesn't think they're
doing anything wrong.
Knowing what I had heard briefly in the dining
room, coupled with pot discussing the hanging
Mike Pence chants in the lobby of our office,
and then Mark's response.
They're to be the riders in the capital that
were chanting for the vice president to be
hung.
Speaker 1: Donald Trump didn't do anything
about the Hang Mike Pence stuff because he
agreed with it.
And for everybody disputing the testimony.
Listen, if Mark Meadows, instead of defying
the committee, showed up, took an oath and
answered questions, we could clear it up.
We could say, hey, you know what?
Now, it's not just Cassidy Hutchinson under
oath.
Now we've got Mark Meadows.
We could get Trump there under oath and have
him answer questions.
Did you think it was reasonable for Mike Pence
to be hung or hanged?
But they don't want to show up.
They're refusing to show up.
So to the extent that people in the media
dispute these claims show up and answer questions
under oath.
Let me know your thoughts.
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
More on these explosive hearings after this
short break.
Okay.
So as yesterday's explosive testimony from
Cassidy Hutchinson was taking place on Washington,
D.C., on Capitol Hill, remember, under oath
in front of the January six committee, Donald
Trump had a complete and total childish meltdown,
untruth, social.
Which only further sort of suggests that the
allegations about his completely losing his
temper and throwing ketchup at the wall are
accurate.
She was under oath.
Trump was untruth.
Speaker 4: Social censure.
Speaker 1: Yes, exactly.
Take a look at this extraordinarily childish
meltdown from Donald Trump on his platform
as the testimony was going on.
Quote, I hardly know who this person, Cassidy
Hutchinson, is, other than I heard very negative
things about her, a total phony and leaker.
And when she requested to go with certain
others of the team to Florida, after my having
served a full term in office, I personally
turned her request down.
Why did she want to go with us if she felt
we were so terrible?
I understand she was very upset and angry
that I didn't want her to go or to be a member
of the team.
She is bad news.
Well, first of all, if she's leaking, she's
leaking accurate information.
You don't leak.
You don't fabricate leaks.
It's either a leak or a lie.
Secondly, she is under huge legal pressure.
It's not that she all of a sudden disagrees
with MAGA.
In fact, this is why I don't see Cassidy Hutchinson
as a hero.
She's acting out of self-preservation.
She's not like some of these other big names.
She is under serious legal pressure here.
And so she showed up and she told the truth
as she recalls it.
Trump, continuing, never complained about
the crowd.
This is the size of the crowd.
CASSIDY Hutchinson testified Trump wasn't
happy with the size of the crowd.
On January 6th, Trump wrote Never complain
about this, about the crowd.
It was massive.
I didn't want or request that we make room
for people with guns to watch my speech.
Who would ever want that?
Not me.
Besides, there were no guns found or brought
into the Capitol building.
So where were all of these guns?
But sadly, a gun was used on Ashley Babbitt
with no price to pay against the person who
used it.
Trump going on her fake story that I tried
to grab the steering wheel of the White House
limousine in order to steer it to the Capitol
building is sick and fraudulent.
Very much like the UN Select Committee itself
wouldn't even have been possible to do such
a ridiculous thing.
Her story of me throwing throwing food is
also false.
And why would she have to clean it up?
I hardly knew who she was.
Well, when you're Trump, lots of people you
hardly know are cleaning up after you, sir.
Then Trump can Trump losing it over this testimony.
She changed lawyers a couple of days ago,
and with it, her story totally changed.
Shocker going on.
Cheney conveniently left out the snippet in
my speech to go peacefully and patriotically.
Isn't she disgraceful?
Trump going on.
There is no cross-examination of this so-called
witness.
This is a kangaroo court.
Well, remember, Republicans opted out of participating
other than Adam Kinzinger and Liz Cheney.
Her body language is that of a total bull
artist.
Fantasyland Trump Continuing.
Will anybody ever be allowed to say the election
was rigged and stolen?
Will the UN select ever discussed that our
country is going to hell because of a fraudulent
election?
How about analyzing the election results?
Trump continuing.
I never said Mike Pence deserves it to be
hung.
Another made up statement by a third rate
social climber.
Trump continuing a total phony.
Trump continuing reacting to a note placed
up on the screen that was written by Cassidy
Hutchinson in bad handwriting, that of a wacko.
Trump continuing.
Why didn't they use the 10,000 troops I offered
up on January 3rd?
There would have been no January 6th.
Actually, there has been no evidence found
that Trump had 10,000 troops ready to go.
No evidence whatsoever.
Trump continuing the woman who was a big Trump
fan long after January 6th.
If her fake stories were true, why would she
want to be was let go and not wanted in Florida?
So she made up phony and completely outrageous
stories, the crazy of which the craziest of
which has already been proven to be a complete
lie.
That's not true.
Nothing has been proven to be a lie.
The Secret Service said, according to the
media, it wasn't true.
Wow.
She has now lost all credibility, just like
the partizan witch hunt perpetuated by the
UN Select Committee of Political Hacks MAGA.
Well, put them under oath, sir.
Put them under oath.
TRUMP Then this morning, waking up with more
of it, saying The New York Times and Washington
Post failed to even mention that today's UN
Select Witness lost all credibility when she
got caught in a ridiculous lie.
Our country has lost all confidence in the
media and our elections.
Sad.
Nothing has been proven false.
Donald Trump completely and totally losing
it in a meltdown of historic proportions.
If anything, Trump melting down this badly
for nearly 24 hours, suggests the claims made
in the committee hearing by Cassidy Hodgkinson
are at least quite plausibly true and should
be investigated.
And if there are people who want to swear
an oath and come in and say I have a different
view, then they should be invited to do it.
But Donald Trump losing it.
Untruth.
Senator Troeth Essential truth social while
Cassidy Hutchinson is under oath.
To me, I know where I'm going to lean in believing
I trust the person whose under oath.
Unless we get some contradictory testimony
under oath.
So that's Trump's reaction.
Let's now go to Fox News's reaction.
This is this is absolutely the best yesterday.
After Cassidy Hutchinson testified that Donald
Trump knew and wanted armed people at his
rally on January 6th that Donald Trump assaulted
a Secret Service agent, tried to commandeer
his vehicle to go to the Capitol, threw food
at the wall, leaving a stain of ketchup, having
to be cleaned up by a number of different
people after all these things happened.
And the testimony was extraordinary.
Fox News was completely in shambles.
First of all, there's a moment where it's
just the silence.
They don't nobody knows what to say.
Nobody has any idea what to say.
It's the most delightful, awkward silence
I've ever seen on Fox News.
Speaker 4: We always point out that there's
not a pushback, and it would have been great
to hear Jim Jordan or some congressman say
some other angle to this.
But the testimony in and of itself is really,
really powerful.
Speaker 1: Sandra you take this one.
Sandra I don't know.
Just the most and the smirk on Brett Bayer's
face about like where do we go from here?
Really says it all.
Speaker 4: Indeed.
Yes, I am here now.
Brett, to your point, I just wonder for the
for the country watching this in this moment,
how much this changes, what people.
Speaker 3: Believed or did not believe.
Speaker 1: Right.
Aside from it being compelling, I mean, does
it even really matter at this point in time?
Now, Brett Bayer then making a very good point
here.
He makes a good point and it's a point I've
made on this program as well.
Cassidy Hutchinson is there in front of the
bright lights under oath while Trump is posting
to his social media platforms.
Speaker 4: Essentially exactly that from hearing
it firsthand, she says that both of those
men requested pardons from the president.
I think what she pointed to, Sandra, was the
most compelling when she quotes Mark Meadows
saying, Pat, you heard the president.
He doesn't care.
He thinks Mike deserves it.
He doesn't think they're doing anything wrong
as far as they're literally, literally calling
for the vice president to be hung.
And then Pat Cipollone, he says, this is f
ing crazy.
According to Hutchinson, this testimony was
very compelling from beginning to end.
She obviously had access to all of the players.
Drew, we are now hearing from the former president
on various posts where he questions her accuracy.
He goes after her directly, says he doesn't
know who she is and said he didn't lunge at
the Secret Service agent in the beast.
That didn't happen.
He says he didn't throw his lunch against
the wall.
That didn't happen.
And that she's lying.
Cassie Hutchinson is under oath on Capitol
Hill.
The president is on truth social.
Making his statement.
What is so compelling?
Speaker 1: I think hard to argue.
I mean, that's absolutely true.
And Fox News just completely unclear on how
to cover this in the immediate aftermath.
Now, later in the show, we'll look at what
the primetime lineup did with the testimony.
They were ready with a smear campaign against
Cassidy Hutchinson.
They were ready to go.
But in the immediate aftermath.
In the immediate aftermath, they didn't know
how.
How do we what do we do here?
And Brett Beyer admitting this is some of
the most jaw dropping testimony ever to take
place in the world of American politics.
Speaker 4: I've covered politics for a long
time.
I don't think there's been testimony like
this that is kind of jaw dropping in a way
on the inside workings of a White House through
crisis after, you know, at this moment and
January 6th that we've seen in since Watergate.
Speaker 1: Right.
And he's absolutely correct.
So by the end of this news hour, they were
starting to put together their reaction plan.
And Martha MACCALLUM shows up towards the
end of the show and sort of just starts to
downplay the significance of the testimony.
This was the first step in kind of minimizing
it.
Later in the evening, Fox News went full out
smear campaign on Cassidy Hutchinson.
We'll get to that.
But here is Martha MACCALLUM trying to run
a little bit of interference.
Speaker 4: I would say, John, you know, I'd
agree with what you all have just been talking
about, but I would say that we had sort of
the basic parameters of what happened with
regard to this.
We had heard before that the president wanted
to go to the capital.
Speaker 1: And understand the strategy.
Here is all along, when we were hearing these
things, they were denying that they were true.
Now that the testimony has gotten so specific
and explosive from people so close to Trump,
now they go, these aren't even really new
revelations.
Well, you denied the revelations were accurate.
Speaker 4: Originally to push back against
that.
So what we're getting today are a lot of details
and fill in in just how dramatic that whole
situation was.
I think that she comes across very credible.
She has a good memory for all of these different
conversations that were being had.
And clearly the description of what happened
in the beast, which is the president's vehicle,
of course, of him wanting to lunge toward
the steering wheel, according to this account
from Bobby, who was the security Secret Service
person who was in the vehicle who she says
was very shaken up afterwards.
The question is, you know, all of this is
obviously riveting.
It's very dramatic.
It was clearly a very difficult day for for
her and for those who were involved.
Right.
Everybody who witnessed it, I would add.
But the question is, in terms of the Department
of Justice, does it move the ball at all on
any legal action that they could pursue?
Or is it sort of an overall filling in the
gaps, filling in the story that has an impact
on whether or not the former president decides
to run again?
And whether or not any of these details impact
people's feelings about that.
All right.
Speaker 1: Even if it's all true, even though
we downplayed it and denied it all along,
and even if Donald Trump was a completely
unhinged, authoritarian madman, hell bent
on keeping a presidency, that he didn't actually
win and indifferent to the potential hanging
of his vice president.
Even if all of that is true, which we ran
interference for for the last year and a half,
does it really matter at this point?
Just an incredible, incredible way to downplay
it.
And just remember, they had 5 hours to get
organized before primetime hit later on last
night.
And after the break, we will look at what
became a concerted and calculated smear campaign
against Cassidy Hutchinson.
That's after the break.
If you're just listening today and you want
to check out video of these clips that I've
been playing for you, make sure that you follow
us on Instagram.
You can find us on Instagram The David Pakman
Show.
So as we already looked at in the immediate
aftermath of the testimony this week from
Cassidy Hutchinson before the January six
committee like in the hour right after it,
Fox News was completely in shambles.
Awkward silences.
Brett Baker having no choice but to concede.
This is some of the most jaw dropping testimony
since Watergate.
They didn't know how do we downplay this?
How do we manage this?
By the time the night time came during the
so-called opinion programing, they had a strategy.
And the strategy is smear campaign against
Cassidy.
Hutchinson.
Cassidy Hutchinson, who has really nothing
to gain from doing this other than then certainly
receiving death threats, which I'm sure she
started to receive by now and hoping to avoid
legal jeopardy, which is why I imagine someone
of her position would say, Yeah, I'll show
up and tell the truth as I recall it.
The smear campaign starts immediately.
First and foremost, they start accusing Hutchinson
of lying, just making it up for personal gain.
How would that benefit her?
Hmm.
Okay, let's listen.
Speaker 4: I served with both Bobby and Tony.
They are career civil service agents, their
former military.
They embody what career government officials
should be.
I would take their word over any word of this
junior staffer who is completely, I believe,
lying to the January six Committee for Own
Self Game, Bobby and Tony.
Speaker 1: So, first of all, Bobby and Tony
are not under oath.
Cassidy Hutchinson is under oath.
If we put them under oath and they have a
conflicting account now, we'll have something
to evaluate.
For the time being, we have Cassidy Hutchinson
under oath, needing security now, receiving
threats now getting doxxed, etc. under oath.
And we have Trump posting on Truth Social
and we have media reports of two Secret Service
agents allegedly claiming that if they testified
under oath, they would have something different
to say.
But they want to say she's just making it
all up.
Speaker 4: Acted appropriately every single
time I travel with the president over 40 separate
trips with those two individuals.
I would love to hear them contradict this
lie with the truth.
But, you know, I'm a little different on this
one.
Bobby and Tony need to continue to serve America.
We don't need to put them on full blast.
Speaker 1: Oh, okay.
So don't.
They're busy doing work.
So even though they would say something different
under oath, we shouldn't actually bring them
in to testify.
So the weakest possible attempt at smearing
her.
Then we go to Laura Ingram.
Laura Ingram has Stephen Miller on and Miller
goes.
She was such a low level aide, but that doesn't
really contradict the subject matter or the
substance of what she says.
She could be a low level aide or not and still
have seen the things she says she saw.
Speaker 4: Reach that way to get.
I couldn't remember.
But it's been the whole you know, the whole
story seemed ridiculous.
But you knew you knew Cassidy Hutchison.
What kind of a you know, I've met her a few
times, but I didn't really have much contact.
Look, she really she's an extremely.
Speaker 2: Junior, low level aide.
I don't think I ever had a.
Speaker 4: Conversation with her that.
Speaker 2: I can at least recall of any.
Speaker 4: Of any substance or death.
But but to Molly's point, this is a and remember.
Speaker 1: The fact that Stephen Miller didn't
have deep conversations with Cassidy Hutchinson
doesn't mean she's not telling the truth.
Speaker 2: Test for your sanity.
If you heard this story and you thought, Man,
I believe every word of this, I'm going to
go on line and say something about it energetically
that something.
Speaker 4: Is wrong with you, something is
wrong with you.
Speaker 1: Right?
If you.
Speaker 4: Believe.
Speaker 1: She might be telling the truth,
you're the crazy person.
Instead, you should believe Stephen Miller
and Laura Ingram.
Ingram, who, by the way, was quite literally
texting Mark Meadows about the riots, saying
one thing and then went on TV that night and
said a completely different thing, running
interference, saying it could have been the
feds, it could have been Antifa, could have
been just certainly wasn't Trumpist or anything
like that.
She wants us to believe her view about Cassidy
Hodgkinson when she was implicated in trying
to manage the media coverage of those very
same riots.
And then Ingram continues saying that the
entire testimony seemed like an audition for
The View.
Speaker 4: Do you notice she kept saying something,
something to that effect.
She kept couching everything she said.
A lot of it was hearsay, obviously not admissible
in any kind of real accord.
But she kept saying something to that effect
always about Trump's reaction to Pence and
the hanging chant to it.
But I found it almost like she was auditioning
for a seat at The View or.
Speaker 1: Now the fact that she would say
something to the effect of to me doesn't really
raise any red flags.
I mean, it seems natural if you're under oath
and you're not quoting something verbatim
that you would use that phrase.
Just think about an instance in your mind.
If I think back, this is just something so
banal, right?
Let's think back to when I had a chipped tooth
repaired a year and a half ago at my dentist.
I remember vividly.
It's not every day that I chip a tooth and
it's not every day that I get the tooth repaired.
So I generally remember the experience.
If you said to me, What exactly did your dentist
say about what probably caused it, I wouldn't
be able to quote my dentist.
So if I were under oath, I would go, Listen,
my dentist said something to the effect of
my bite and potentially grinding my teeth
that night led to the chip.
It's accurate.
That was the that that was the gist of what
was said.
It's completely representative of my dentist's
view.
But I don't remember the words that were used.
It was a year and a half ago, so I would naturally
say something like, Well, the dentist made
me understand that this was the cause.
The dentist said something to the effect of
the fact that Cassidy Hutchinson is using
that term does not to me raise any red flags.
Now, she may just not be telling the truth,
but right now we don't have any contradictory
claims under oath.
Put someone under oath and let's get some
contradictory claims.
Okay, then, then.
HANNITY What was the next one?
He Oh, no.
Ingram also spoke to other people about Cassidy
Hutchinson.
Speaker 4: Now, the first attempted distraction
or shiny object, a former aide to Mark Meadows,
Cassidy Hutchinson, was slotted into what
was billed as a special, super duper special
session of the January six committee today.
And I spoke with some former White House staffers,
three or four of them in the afternoon, and
they knew her well.
And not one person had anything good to say
about her performance today.
Speaker 1: Well, why does it matter why?
Extremely biased people with a vested interest
in minimizing the insanity of what happened.
Think about her performance.
Why does that matter?
The question is, did what she say line up
with other testimony?
The answer is yes.
Did what she say get contradicted by anyone
else testifying under oath?
The answer is no.
And is she in any way likely to benefit from
this, or is she actually exposing herself
both to legal jeopardy and to death threats
and to needing security and to being docs?
And the answer is yes, of course it does.
Sean HANNITY jumping in and participating
on this as well.
He jumped on the word hearsay.
Hearsay has become a big focal point of yesterday's
testimony.
Today, we heard more rumors, a ton of hearsay
and wow, a lot of impeached.
Speaker 4: Testimony that we'll.
Speaker 1: Get to in a second.
And this is why it's never hearsay is never.
Speaker 4: Admissible in a real court of law.
Speaker 1: Including this wild claim from
a former low.
Speaker 4: Level, low.
Speaker 1: Staffer.
Watch this.
Yeah.
So then he goes on to play the testimony.
So the entire hearsay thing.
All right.
There are so so two things on that.
First of all, the fact that Cassidy Hutchinson
is recalling what others said does not really
change our understanding of it in a congressional
hearing.
It is true that there are restrictions on
what hearsay is admissible in courts of law.
We're not even talking about crimes here yet.
So why they continue to talk about hearsay?
Well, we know why, because other people hear
and they go.
It was hearsay.
So.
But does hearsay mean it was false?
Does hearsay mean that she's make it up?
No.
Hearsay relates to courts of law.
This is not a court of law.
But I want to go beyond that.
There are 30 exceptions to hearsay not being
admissible in courts of law.
Oftentimes, hearsay is admissible in a court
of law.
There's the present sense impression.
Exception.
This is a hearsay statement which could be
allowed if it describes or explains something
that happened based on something said by someone
right after it happened.
So when she says, Hey, this is what Mark Meadows
said right as they were chanting Hang Mike
Pence.
I'm not saying it would be allowed in a court
of law, but there is a present sense impression.
Exception to hearsay restrictions in courts
of law, which sometimes can be argued for.
There's what's called the excited utterance
exception.
If you were somewhere and someone made an
excited utterance, it was it happened close
to whatever it was they were reacting to.
It was sort of like a visceral reaction.
It was it it almost even startled the pages
came out of the person making the claim that
can be admissible because it was an excited
utterance and it may not even be something
the person who made the utterance would remember.
Imagine that there's been an explosion.
Happens right in front of you.
That's such an unusual thing.
I might go, Oh, oh, look at this.
I knew.
I knew this was happening.
This was my cousin Joe.
I knew he was going to do I might not even
remember that.
But a court might say to someone who heard
me make that excited utterance, we're going
to we're going to allow that, even though
it's hearsay under the excited utterance exception.
The point here is this attack on everything
is hearsay, as if it's some open and shut
thing.
Well, it's hearsay.
It wouldn't be allowed in a court, and therefore
it can't even be believed in this setting.
It's B.S. and it's a scripted and coordinated
attack.
Last thing.
Mark Levin on Fox News just completely losing
it and demanding that news networks fire their
legal analysts for not properly attacking.
The entire January 6th committee proceedings.
Speaker 2: You also do not participate in
a transition period and ordered the Department
of Defense to work with the Biden people.
Easy, but they have no evidence for any of
this committee's come up with nothing, despite
the fact it's all one way.
And I want to encourage networks all over
the country who I'm sure will listen to me.
Fire your legal analysts.
Fire them.
There's too many former federal prosecutors.
This isn't about a federal prosecution.
These legal guys, they keep coming on.
They know nothing about the Constitution.
A president, a candidate has the right to
lobby and lobby the state legislature if he
or she believes that the electors should be
for them.
Speaker 1: Just because he's yelling doesn't
make it true.
Mark Levin should try decaf.
And he is just furious, furious that not every
legal analyst is saying it's all lies and
it's imprisoned.
The people doing the investigation, Mark Levin
isn't happy.
So that's the totality of the smear campaign
that Fox and the right wing put together in
just a few hours after Cassidy Hutchinson's
testimony.
Okay.
Last thing on yesterday's testimony in the
January six committee hearings by Cassidy
Hutchinson.
And this has nothing to do with Cassidy Hutchinson
herself.
Liz Cheney yesterday during the committee
hearings at the end revealed that in Mafia
mob boss style, Trump associated individuals
have been contacting witnesses and sort of
suggesting to them, you should remain loyal.
Be careful what you say.
Here is Liz Cheney revealing what is quite
clearly witness tampering, the intimidation
of January six committee witnesses.
Speaker 3: Here is how one witness described
phone calls from people interested in that
witnesses testimony.
Well, what they said to me is as long as I
continue to be a team player, they know I'm
on the right team.
I'm doing the right thing.
I'm protecting who I need to protect.
You know, I'll continue to stay in good graces
in Trumpworld.
And they have reminded me a couple of times
that Trump does read transcripts.
And just keep that in mind as I proceed through
my interviews with the committee.
Speaker 1: Remember, Trump reads transcripts.
That's intimidation.
That's witness tampering.
Speaker 3: Here's another sample in a different
context.
This is a call received by one of our witnesses.
Quote a person.
Let me know.
You have your deposition tomorrow.
He wants me to let you know he's thinking
about you.
He knows you're loyal and you're going to
do the right thing when you go in for your
deposition.
Speaker 1: Right.
You're going to do the right thing.
Speaker 3: I think most Americans know that
attempting to influence witnesses to testify
truthfully presents very serious concerns.
Speaker 1: Yes.
And so this is the latest.
Even within.
So the the hearings are looking at what took
place and may find that crimes took place
in relation to the hearings.
It appears as though more criminality is taking
place.
Our friend Jamie Raskin recently appeared
on our program.
Congressman Jamie Raskin was asked about this
and its potential criminality.
And here is what he had to say of witness
tampering.
Speaker 5: The.
Well, the evidence of witness tampering that
the committee has released or the two episodes
that the vice chair cited today anonymously
for obvious reasons.
It's a crime to tamper with witnesses.
Correct.
Form of obstructing justice.
The committee won't tolerate it.
And we haven't had a chance to fully investigated
or fully discuss it.
But it's something on our.
Speaker 1: Agenda, folks.
There may be people charged with crimes in
relation to the committee, like they think
about the multilayered insanity of that.
You've got the subject matter being investigated
by the committee, which could lead to criminal
charges, but you could have subsequently an
investigation into Trump worlds actions related
to the investigative committee.
And there may be crimes there.
It's crimes all the way down, seemingly unbelievable
what is going on?
We're going to take a quick break.
We're going to get to other stories, including
new polling about the 2022 midterms and much
more.
Stay with me.
There's been a dramatic turn of events in
2022, polling over the last couple of months.
And I don't want to overstate this, but I
also don't want to ignore the story because
when three, four months ago, I was saying,
guys, listen, everyone must vote and we have
to do everything, fight for every seat, all
of these things.
But it's not looking great for Democrats in
2022.
I think Democrats will lose the House.
I think Democrats will lose the Senate.
Some of you wrote to me and said, David, why
are you writing it off?
You should just say we can win it.
Well, I'm not writing it off.
I'm just telling you what the polling is and
I'm being realistic.
The polling has reversed, reversed dramatically.
And Democrats are now ahead of Republicans
in three recent polls looking at a generic
2022 ballot.
A generic 2022 ballot means regardless of
where you are, you plan to vote for the Democrat
or for the Republican.
This is not normal.
And again, now there's the risk of another
unintended consequence of mentioning this,
which is if I say, oh, Democrats are doing
great now, then people will say, Well, I don't
need to vote.
I don't quite frankly think this show is big
enough to have that much of an effect one
way or the other.
But we all must vote.
But we should understand the numbers.
Three new polls in a new Marist poll in a
congressional ballot.
Democrats, 48, Republicans, 41.
That's a plus seven.
For Democrats, that's a big, big deal.
In a new Politico morning consult poll, Democrats
45.
Republicans 42.
That's plus three for Democrats.
And then in a new Yahoo News YouGov poll,
Democrats, 45.
Republicans, 38.
That's plus seven for Democrats.
Why are these numbers such a big deal?
There's two reasons.
Number one, this is not typically what you
see when one party has taken the White House
in the previous election, in 2020, Democrats
took the White House from Republicans.
Biden beat Trump.
You all know that.
And typically, almost always with like three
exceptions.
When that happens, you would expect Republicans
to do really well in the first midterms, which
would be four and a half months from now in
November.
So, number one, the fact that the numbers
differ from that traditional historical reality
is a really big deal.
But the second reason that it's a really big
deal is this is not the way the numbers look
just three months ago.
And I think that we can all sort of take a
cynical approach here and say this is temporary.
It'll go back to Republicans crushing Democrats
by November.
Well, it's not obvious to me, but one of the
things we've been talking about now for about
two months is, are there unique circumstances
in this election that make it potentially
okay for Democrats when Republicans should
be winning?
And I say that the answer is yes.
This is not a guarantee of anything.
I'm still getting a lot of people on Twitter
saying, David, you loser.
Some of them say worse things than that.
Republicans are going to crush Democrats in
November.
Just wait and see.
Well, maybe, but there are some different
circumstances here.
First of all, normally when we say, oh, Democrats
can win by running on abortion rights, know
that historically that's not a good issue
for Democrats to run on.
It's not a winning issue.
It's not a voting issue for Democrats.
It's the type of issue that will motivate
Republicans to come out to vote against a
pro-choice candidate.
Typically, that's the way it is this time
around, it looks like it could be different.
Americans are more in favor of abortion being
legal in most cases than at any time over
the last 50 years.
So public opinion is different now than it
has been on abortion.
And in addition to that, Republican appointed
Republican nominee Trump nominated Supreme
Court justices have overturn Roe v Wade, something
which two thirds of Americans are in disagreement
with.
That is different.
And that means in this election, that situation
could make it better for Democrats, particularly
if they say we're the ones trying to keep
these rights, whether it's credible or not,
that that's what Democrats are going to do.
Secondly, normally running on gun safety regulation
is a losing issue for Democrats.
We've talked about it before.
We've talked about it with a number of political
strategists.
When Democrats make gun safety regulations
a big part of their campaign, it doesn't really
motivate Democrats to come out and vote for
them, but it does motivate Republicans to
come out and vote against them.
However, the rash of school and other mass
shootings in the United States over the last
three months and just tragic numbers, hundreds
of mass shootings in the United States in
2022 so far seem to have tired out and exhausted
many Americans about the Republican Party's
unwillingness to consider serious gun safety
regulations.
And so you have a situation where in this
particular midterm, it might actually work
for Democrats to run on gun safety and on
abortion rights.
So that's.
The normal.
The other element that is different than normal
in these midterms is that we are coming up
against the tail end of this six year Trumpian
cycle.
And I'll explain to you what I mean by that.
Normally, you have a sort of relatively similar
electorate throughout three elections.
So like if you look at, I don't know, 2000,
2002 and 2004, as an example, the electorate
George W Bush won the presidency in 2000.
And then you had the 2002 midterms.
And Bush won reelection in 2004.
There was no major change to the electorate
in the year 2000, which then had to sort of
sort itself out in 2000, two.
And in 2004, it was a very similar electorate.
Okay.
That is not the case right now.
In 2016, you had all of these formerly nonpolitical,
nonvoting people who were enamored with Trump,
a lot of low information voters, a lot of
extremists of different kinds, people who
were clueless.
All these people were not participating in
politics before 2016.
They appeared in 2016.
And then in 2018, some of them voted in the
midterms.
And then in 2020, they were still around and
trying to get Trump reelected and now Trump's
gone.
And there's a real question as to do these
Trumps vote in midterms where now Trump isn't
even a candidate and Trump is less visible
and so many other things are going on?
Or do those people that only entered the political
space thanks to Trump's presence, do they
just kind of go back to whatever they were
doing before?
I don't know what that is, but it didn't include
voting.
We don't know the answer to that.
But it's potentially something that will really
change the makeup of the 2022 midterm electorate.
So do I have a definitive answer?
I don't.
But when we see Republicans were winning every
generic ballot three months ago, Democrats
are now winning every generic ballot.
That is a major change and potentially significant.
So I'm not ready to count out Democrats in
2022, but we must vote.
We must get involved in campaigns, phone banking,
all of it.
And we'll be doing everything we can to cover
these, to cover the important races and the
mid-terms at large.
I want to mention this, but not spend a ton
of time on it.
Again, people are talking about Hillary 2024.
I've actually seen some op ed ads saying Hillary
is exactly what the Democratic Party needs
in 2024.
This is very hard for me to believe is a good
idea for Democrats in 2024.
One such article talking about this is by
CNN's editor at large, Chris Cillizza.
It's an article called The Whispers of Hillary
Clinton 2024 have started.
And Cillizza writes In the immediate aftermath
of the Supreme Court decision to overturn
Roe v Wade.
Conservative writer John Ellis went to the
Internet to make a provocative case.
It's time for Hillary Clinton to make another
political comeback.
He wrote, quote, Now is her moment.
The Supreme Court's decision to overturn Roe
v Wade creates the opening for Hillary Clinton
to get out of stealth mode and start down
the path towards declaring her candidacy for
the 2024 Democratic nomination.
Ellis's argument is one, Joe Biden will be
82 and is just going to be too old to run
again.
And number two, the Democratic bench is not
terribly strong.
He's not the only person eyeing a Clinton
reemergence going on to write that.
Juan Williams, the Democratic pundit, recently
made the case that Clinton should become a
major figure on the campaign trail this year
to reset herself as a potential candidate
for 2024.
I have two thoughts on this, because I've
been talking about there needs to we need
someone else.
We need.
There needs to be someone else here.
And continuing to recycle the same candidates
doesn't seem like a great idea.
Hillary Clinton is no spring chicken herself.
Okay.
In 2024, she'll be 76 at the time of the 2024
election.
So the idea that Biden's too old at 82.
So what Democrats need is 76 year old Hillary
Clinton.
I don't know that that's like a super strong
argument to me.
But there's this intangible feeling that even
if you can at some kind of micro-level, make
this case that the Democratic Party is just
ready for something different now.
I've said some of the people I'm interested
in are Jamie Raskin.
I know anti-Semitism could be maybe a problem
for him, but I think Jamie Raskin would be
a fascinating candidate.
I would love to vote for Jamie Raskin.
I think Jon Ossoff, the senator from Georgia,
super interesting, although maybe he's not
yet experienced enough.
Maybe too young.
I've listed other people who I think are interesting.
None of them have the name recognition of
Hillary Clinton, and I can see that right
away.
But it seems like exactly the type of mistake
that Democrats love to make to say, now, let's
go with Hillary once again, I just am not
seeing it.
And it sounds like a disastrous idea, but
I want to hear from you.
Let me know what you think about this idea
of Hillary. 2024.
We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192.
David P. I've talked about people canceling
memberships.
Here's someone who's so furious about our
recent guest hosts that he's signing up for
memberships merely to cancel them.
Listen to this.
Speaker 4: Hello, this is Alan from New Jersey.
I'm calling to speak to Pat because Pat just
claims that Billy did a good jobs substitute
hosting the show.
Yeah, he really did not do a good job.
You did a terrible job.
And I need to cancel my membership and then
cancel it a second time.
That's how disappointed I am.
Move Beasley is.
I can't cancel once I have to cancel my membership,
then sign up again and then cancel the second
time.
Right.
Show how disappointed I am.
And Luke Beasley, he's horrible.
Is Pat or Farron Cousins are No.
One.
Wow.
The only two options, Pat.
They're cousins or no one.
Speaker 1: Wow.
Very, very strong.
Now, obviously, he's kidding about signing
up just to cancel memberships.
Extremely strong feelings about our guest
hosts.
Every guest hosts got rave reviews and terrible
reviews.
So we're we're not picking on Luke Beasley
here at all.
There were people who wrote to me and said
Luke was fantastic, but I can't stand Baron's
facial hair and I didn't like Pat's delivery.
There were people who wrote in and said, Pat's
great.
He knows the flow of the show.
Everybody else is bad.
There were others who wrote in and said, The
only guy ready for prime time is Farren, Pat
and Luke.
Don't know what they're doing.
Listen, hopefully there was a little bit of
something for everybody.
That's the hope.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Stacks of bodies found dead in a trailer.
A horrifying story.
We will we will talk about it.
Elizabeth Warren says Democrats are two votes
away from codifying Roe v Wade, but is it
too late?
And a study finds that cannabis users are
25% more likely to need emergency care or
hospitalization.
But is it because of the cannabis I know I
mentioned these were yesterday's stories.
Yesterday's bonus show was canceled.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves as bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Because of yesterday's emergency house committee
hearing, the bonus show was canceled.
So we will do those stories today sign up
for the bonus show at joined Pacman dot com
you can use the coupon code indict that's
I and I t indict you all know what it means.
Everybody knows what that means right now.
Sign up at join pacman dot com.
I'll see you on the bonus show or otherwise
back here tomorrow.